3 2 1 2 le coup d'envoi de cette
deuxième édition de drop en scène et
donner France Angleterre Samoa ou encore
Pays de Galles tous les pays présents à
la Coupe du Monde 2023 ils sont
représentés 8 villes linoises
participent à cet événement dont boisfle
qui voit de multiples intérêts donc
l'idée c'est d'abord de donner
envie de dire entre commune et puis
aussi effectivement puisque là on a
aussi des IME sur place donc la place
pour tous dans le cadre du sport
le respect des valeurs le partage et la
bienveillance était donc mis en avant
durant l'événement qui souhaitait aussi
avoir un intérêt culturel
[Applaudissements]
on a demandé donc aux villes aux écoles
de travailler sur le pays qu'il
représente donc drapeau connaissance du
drapeau de l'hymne national des couleurs
de leur équipe donc on voit très bien
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des il y a des
villes qui ont qui sont venues avec les
couleurs qui ont dessiné les drapeaux
qui ont travaillé sur la culture de
chaque pays c'était aussi le but aussi
de de cette opération
l'idée c'est du lait commune et les
enfants qui prennent plaisir à découvrir
ce sport tout en restant très compétitif
on est mieux pour découvrir un sport
après il y a des personnes du club les
plus aidés pour nous donner des
stratégies et des tactiques et on tente
de mettre ça en place pour les grands
gagnants un trophée et une opportunité
unique de représenter comme il se doit
leur commune